yeah man this series is awesome i've
only seen four episodes because that's
all they gave us but i can't wait to see
the rest but
stu what was it about this character
that made you want to commit
to this mini series james good question
well there's many reasons i wanted
to do the series i mean stephen king i
haven't done a king project i'm a
gigantic fan it happened since i was
young i think this is
you know one of his masterpieces um top
three for me
so and then you see the cast you see
whoopi and alexander
and and everybody it's just you know
tremendous thing to be a part of but i
think
what drew me to stu is you know it i'd
be lying to you if i didn't
draw any sort of comparisons to the way
i grew up i grew up in
in oklahoma and um you know small little
midwest
area um and uh you know there was a
there was a simplicity to the lifestyle
and um
you know i think stu represents this
sort of ordinary man
um thrust into extraordinary
circumstances
welcome to the boulder-free zone stu
redmond
which one of you is larry underwood how
do you know who i am
how do you think mother abigail oh i
know that we dreamed of her and she was
real
she brought us all together to keep us
safe in these uncertain times
and he's a guy with a really strong
moral code
and and you know really wants to be
defined as somebody who's virtuous and
and a good man
whether he's flashy or not because he's
not um
but those are the kind of heroes that
i'm drawn to uh the ones that the
reluctant ones that are just
they don't view themselves as heroes
they view themselves as somebody who's
just doing the right thing
yeah and i think he's got good you know
he's got a good rigid sense of morals
and
a strong black and white sense of what's
right wrong and
and i think that's that kind of makes
him a natural leader when he gets to
boulder
yeah well you said heroes now you played
your fair share of heroes and some
villains along the way
in your career so i gotta ask you like
who do you enjoy playing most the good
guy the bad guy
what do you have more fun doing yeah i
mean i guess if you're
if you're defining it as fun i'd
probably say the bad guys maybe
it's nice to be a little reckless at
least when it comes to playing like you
gotta remind people that you can you
know that you at least can
understand the dark side of some people
and the dark side of humanity
and that that can be intoxicating and
and uh
um fun to play uh you know on
on the first season of dead to me it was
a blast i mean i was just
you know i like taking my villains and
portraying them in a way that you're
actually kind of poking fun at them
um you know those kinds of people uh but
it's you know
it's a lot of it's a lot of fun to to
let yourself go and
explore the dark corners of your mind
with the with the villains
without a doubt i feel like everything
i've watched in pandemic from westworld
dead to me and now this i'm like james
james margin jimmy's everywhere so i
can't get away from you that's okay
that's true man it's like you get to
turn the tv on it's i feel very grateful
for that but uh yeah you just go to
cable and i'm
you know it's like a greatest hits uh so
i hope it doesn't make people i hope you
didn't get sick of me hope you're
watching
some other things other than my stuff
it's a good problem to have that is for
sure now
speaking of problems we got a whole heck
of a lot of problems here in 2020
especially with this pandemic
how in the world does stephen king
predict some of the crises that we are
facing right now this year
considering you wrote this book to stand
back in 1978
like say what what did he know that we
didn't
yeah it's a great question i mean we
only decided to pay attention to it
until you know it now just now with the
world shutting down and going through
what it's going through
um but look i mean the guy's brilliant i
think the word genius gets thrown
thrown around too casually nowadays but
he he genuinely is one and
um he has a real curiosity about
humanity
and about where we're going and and and
and exploring those those things that
scare us that we're out that we don't
the mysteries of where we're going
on this earth and and what could what
could stop us what could end it all
and um i think he probably found himself
exploring
those those ideas back in the 70s and
you know it's going to be it'll be it'll
not with a bang but with a whisper
you know i think it's it's probably
something that resonated in his head
i actually would love to ask him what's
coming next